North Philadelphia born and raised in a
giant base is where he spent most of his
days this is physics at its most
mesmerizing Greg Kennedy is the only
juggler on earth to nail nine balls of
light in a gigantic cone this guy
doesn't even like juggling but no one
will let him out of the cone we're in
Philly to enter the cone zone and shed
some light on Greg's captivating skills
I always like to challenge myself some
of the things you might see me do in the
tone is not something that took a month
or a year I've been working on some of
those patterns for a decade now I'm
coming up with whole new things that
nobody ever dreamed of and for me that's
part of being human part of being a lot
who wants to lift the lid on this
bewildering ball show Greg skill is in
how he throws those balls he doesn't let
them bounce but he said rolls them
smoothly around the inside of the cone
once they're on the wall and traveling
the centrifugal effect keeps the ball
stuck to the wall it's trying to travel
in a straight line but the shape of the
cone is moving it in a curve and this
means at all times the ball is pushing
on the wall and the wall is pushing back
on the ball so if I take a ball and I
throw it horizontally with the right
energy it'll stay in a perfect circle
I can also do that down low but I'll
have to throw with a little less energy
I can take that ball and I can throw it
downwards with a lot of energy and it
will come back up
I can also throw it upward and it'll go
down and back up but how do Greg's balls
go down and back up again each Bowl is
being forced to follow a curved path
which means it's getting angular
momentum angular momentum is a conserved
quantity that means that unless some
outside force acts on the balls the
angular momentum will remain the same
angular momentum depends on three things
the mass of the ball it's distance from
the center of rotation which in this
case is a central axis of the cone and
how fast the ball is moving if you
change one of these things the other two
has to change so that the total is
always the same
because each ball is making its way down
the cone due to gravity
it means the tightness of its curve is
getting smaller
that forces the ball to get faster just
to keep and your momentum is the same
the faster each ball gets the greater
the centrifugal effect acting upon it
which is pushing it outwards but because
it's in a cone it effectively goes
upwards it's circus with science over
time as I gotten older I figured out it
was gonna be better for me to continue
juggling less with my body and a little
bit more with my mind my contribution at
this point is actually expanding the
realm of juggling and creating new
concepts and in a lot of ways I think
that's gonna be my legacy Greg you
totally own the cone